herr weber das ist das schlechteste
ergebnis seit 1949 der union insgesamt
wie groß ist der csu anteil an diesem
schlechtesten ergebnis wir haben
gemeinsam als cdu und csu gekämpft und
wir müssen gemeinsam das wahlergebnis
verantworten in bayern hat die
schlussmobilisierung noch funktioniert
die sorgen der bürgerinnen bürger vor
einem linksruck in deutschland hat in
bayern gefruchtet und da war der
csu-parteitag sich auch am wendepunkt er
uns dazu geholfen hat wir stehen der
gemeinsamen verantwortung und müssen
jetzt verhindern dass linke ideologen
ins kanzleramt kommen zumindest die
hinter olaf scholz stellen wenn ihre
schlussoffensive funktioniert hat was
wäre dann möglich gewesen wenn die
bayern also die csu markus söder
wirklich armin laschet unterstützt hatte
die hatten diskussionen um den
kanzlerkandidaten die war aber beendet
und wir wollen jetzt gemeinsam in die
zukunft gehen wollen gemeinsam die
chance besteht nämlich mit grünen und
mit der fdp regierung zu bilden die
chance wollen müssen noch einen satz
sozusagen aus der brüsseler aus der
europäischen sicht was wird jetzt von
europa von der eu erwartet wie schnell
muss es eine stabile regierung in berlin
geben und was sind aus ihrer sicht die
wichtigsten akzente die von dieser
regierung dann gesetzt werden müssen auf
europäischer ebene ist das wichtigste
weder die afd noch die linke haben eine
chance in europa eine
regierungsverantwortung zu kommen beide
optionen das radikale parteien sich
beteiligen sind ausgeschlossen insofern
ist die signale nach europa es wird in
europa in deutschland eine
proeuropäische eine partnerschaftliche
regierung geben die der verantwortung
gerecht wird europa zu gestalten und wir
werden alles dafür tun dass der
brückenbauer armin laschet danach kannst
du wert und sollte dann der brückenbauer
olaf scholz heißen würde das in brüssel
und bei ihnen sehr viel anders gesehen
war er hat ja eigentlich was die
europäische angeht ebene angeht viel
mehr erfahrung als ein gewisser armin
laschet
alle parteien die jetzt in
regierungsverantwortung kommen können
entstehen zu einem geeinten europa das
ist das richtige signal allerdings muss
man auch muss man auch klar sagen dass
wenn eben eher linkes denken kommt
ideologisches denken kommt wird es
gerade mit ost- und westeuropa er zu
spaltungstendenzen in europa führen wir
brauchen im kanzleramt jemanden der auch
mit mittelosteuropa reden kann auf
brücken bauen kann auf die zugehen kann
und dass das ist mit vielen dank viel
herzlichen dankeschön